greetings mere mortals in this video
i'll be presenting a rather grandiose
list of the utmost importance for it is
today where we shine the spotlight on
our grandest villains in the anime world
yes we'll be taking a deep dive into the
villainous side of the anime world
because when you're in a show with a lot
of bad guys and they're inflated egos
there is only room for one isn't that
let's take a look at some of my favorite
villain versus villain showdowns in
anime we start off with hunter hunter
the chimera ants are among the more
interesting villains in the series their
competition for the spot the phantom
troop they both have their charismatic
members who have a lot of redeeming
aspects to their character in terms of
morality or in the case of hisoka just
plain entertainment however it's hard to
root for either side when the sadistic
torture technician faithan battles the
selfish and conceited zazan like the
assassin that he is feitan approaches
the fight with more trickery and cunning
something that hopefully puts him on par
with zazon's sheer power in a
straight-up battle little can be done to
compensate for the difference in
physical prowess however faith dan's
pain packer ends up being the great
equalizer in the battle of the two
villains i find feitan the lesser evil
at least for the moment anyway it's
quite an entertaining fight that i can
confidently call one of the highlights
of the ark
shigaraki vs rudestro is up next
my hero academia has no shortage of
villains however when it comes to the
head honchos at the top of the food
chain they can only be roomed for one
vying for the hole left by all for one's
defeat the league of villains shigaraki
goes on a collision course with leader
of the meta liberation army taking their
own underlings with them in a conflict
that leaves the city at the mercy of
their destructive powers the whole arc
is full of villain versus villain fights
something that i didn't expect out of a
shonen despite having the more sinister
goal i think the shigeraki comes off as
a more charismatic one and that's the
one who i'm inclined to side with in
this conflict due to having a more
compelling backstory the fight itself is
a spectacle that you'd be better off
watching for yourself there's no
shortage of drama and it seems that the
two titans will keep throwing haymakers
at each other or leading to a thrilling
conclusion
following that we have kaido versus big
mom ah kaido and big mom wouldn't the
two peak villains eventually put fans in
a power level debate on who's the
strongest and baddest pirate of them all
well fans of power level debates you
won't have to wait any longer episode
950 of one piece is a landmark episode
as both of these gargantuan forces
finally clash the heavens split and the
earth shakes as the two powerhouses
collide throwing their abilities at each
other you know i personally love how
kaido's conqueror haki was depicted in
the anime but big mom's responses aren't
too shabby either she holds her ground
rather magnificently despite the eye
test favoring kaido at first glance but
hey why fight each other when you can
just form an alliance and conquer the
world thus the two put their differences
aside and give birth to an unholy
alliance one that will shake the world
to its core watch out
with this extensive rogues gallery it's
no surprise that jojo has one of these
villain face-offs
let's take something from recent history
now shall we remember the time when
dopio battled risotto in golden wind
it's a whole arc in itself and i still
get excited seeing metallica take on
king crimson it's as wacky as you'd
expect any jojo fight to be but it's got
more layers of awesomeness when you look
at it in depth there's the awesome
revelation of metallica's power as well
as dopio's true identity the fight is
also a showcase of how dangerous its
iron manipulation really is it seems
that all hope is lost for dopio before
aerosmith enters the fray turning the
tides of the battle for good risotto
gets offered mercy but i like how he
just says screw it and makes a defiant
last stand even on the verge of death
it's a treat of a villain fight being
written as more of a scrappy underdog
duel that ends with a dramatic
turnaround of epic proportions
we've got fights of plenty coming ahead
but what i'm most concerned for is the
fight that involves us now that is our
battle against hackers in the
battlefield called the internet that's
why i present to you our number one
weapon against hackers or unpleasant
personalities looking to extract our
data it's the sponsors of this video
expressvpn thanks to expressvpn i found
myself browsing the internet without any
fear even when i've been in countries
that have heavily regulated internet you
don't need to be a tech wizard to make
this work i use it just this weekend to
watch hunter hunter which isn't
available in the uk all i had to do was
open up expressvpn and select the united
states server and boom now i can watch
hunter hunter like dozens of other anime
on netflix break region locks overcome
villains trying to get your personal
info and surf without suffering any
slowdowns in internet speed so what's
not to like no other vpn i've used comes
anywhere close to expressvpn in terms of
effectiveness ease of access and value
for money you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by following the
link below or typing in
www.expressvpn.com
vinnie tube a world of safe browsing and
an internet free of limitations are at
your fingertips okay let's return to
more villain versus villain battles
for fate's representative is actually a
pretty close call for me i wasn't sure
whether i'd give this the nod over
gilgamesh versus berserker in the end
this did win why you ask well gilgamesh
is brash and arrogant while berserker is
just a force of nature looking to kill
our protagonist however i don't think
either of them are actually evil in
their core the same can't be said of our
two combatants here the fallen priest
and unholy patriarch of the matos this
feud between the two villains stretched
through the three heavens feels movie
but they would finally get their hands
on each other in spring song assisted by
assassin zokin tries to maneuver his
pieces and get rid of kirei only for the
priest to outsmart him and finally
exercise his body now it's not as grand
as gilgamesh versus berserker but i feel
that this battle symbolizes what i like
about evil versus evil battles instead
of a straight up battle of strength this
long confrontation is more of a series
of mind games and careful plotting
[Music]
one punch man has one of these two
speeder sounds sonic and deep sea king
are up next
there are a few things bigger than a
humongous supervillain's ego and we see
that in full display when deep sea king
coming off a solid win dares sonic to
defy him having just as big of an ego as
the gargantuan deep-sea king sonic
obviously responds in kind resulting in
an impromptu face-off between the two
fighters with completely different
profiles in a similar vein to phaeton
and zazan we have a speed versus power
fight here sonic also starts off on the
offensive quick and despite everything
that deep sea king can throw at him he
keeps dodging or outmaneuvering them
like zaza deep sea king unleashes an
empowered form that allows him to
finally get his hands on sonic only to
have his plan thwarted again the ninja
having escaped his grasp and swearing
victory next time classic fast-paced
action here it's a fight that's short
but sweet helped a lot by one punch
man's excellent animation
gintama has one hell of a villain versus
villain fight in takasugi versus
we've got yet another quickie in
takasugi vs obero's battle towards the
end of the rakuyo decisive battle arc
towards the waning moments of the ark
after obero had gone through a hell of a
gauntlet which included the likes of the
shin sengumi and gintoki he encounters
his final opponent takasugi the fight's
just as you'd expect from two high tier
fighters lots of sword clashes and
physical blows there's the overarching
theme of an eye for an eye which holds a
lot more weight given obero's backstory
the two finally clash quick draw style
with dakar tsugi coming out on top but
dying takes a toll you know but i think
that in terms of the narrative it's
better to have the fight to be direct
and to the point the accompanying
backstory also doubles as a fitting and
touching farewell for obero some wonky
animation here and there doesn't detract
too much from the battle in the story
overall
[Music]
we cap off this list with something from
fma greed versus wrath
[Music]
among the villains in fma i'm personally
partial to greed there's just something
about that wild card nature of his that
attracts me so much he's also got one
hell of a character story to tell once
the events of the series are done and
it's his unpredictability that opens the
door to interesting fights like the one
he had versus wrath on paper wrath
should have the upper hand but greed has
ling's guidance to help him as well as
lots and lots of backup it's really cool
how the fight makes it seem that the two
villains can go toe to toe with one
another despite one supposedly being a
lot stronger if we look at storyline
importance instead greed forces wrath to
go deep into his bag of tricks activates
his eye power only for him to actually
find a way to actually overcome the
ultimate eye it's a touch and go fight
full of momentum shifts and while it's
not as memorable as any of mustangs
outbursts or wrath's best fights it's a
pretty good example of villain versus
villain done right this is also a fight
that happens on route to greed's final
redemption if you can call it that so
greed fans should find this fight extra
special
so which is your favorite villain versus
villain moment in anime i'd love to know
so don't hesitate to chime in on the
comment section if you enjoyed the video
please leave a like and if you want to
support me which i think you should
don't waste any more time come and check
out my memberships and see what vinnie
tube has to offer you can also visit my
patreon to support me more directly your
pledges won't be for naught don't forget
to check out our sponsors of this video
expressvpn all you have to do is click
the link in the description box or go to
expressvpn.com
vinnie tube for a three month free trial
with that we end the video and i hope
that you enjoyed watching it remember to
subscribe so that you can be the first
in line next time around and i hope to
see you again
you